[Music]
so today we're gonna try vlogging on the
hero 5 GoPro so this is this is what
we're doing we're driving there's also
in this super view mode so everything is
really really super now we're in the
wide view what's this look like there's
a little bit better than the super view
we're now in the medium field of view
what's it look like because I don't have
a clue just to really get crazy and
switch things up this is the linear
field of view linear field of view hmm
now last but not least is the narrow
field of view so now that we've got
these covered which one do you guys like
the best just literally I'm driving and
I haven't edited this video yet
I hate thriller parking Wow right we're
currently shooting in 1080p 60 frames a
second probably gonna stick with the
1080 60 frames or this entire vlog just
to keep things consistent I've got
really big plans for a GoPro video so
basically I'm making this little
contraption where I can take all your
GoPros and I'm going to attach them to
this device and I'm gonna test it out I
love it we've got other hero 5 fans
apparently it's gonna be really cool to
kind of put them all side-by-side to
sort of get a real feel for what's what
so right now we're gonna cook it a
manicure
[Music]
and the best part about that salon
they've got really great chrome nails
and we have life savers it's now to
continue on the rest of the day here in
the GoPro vlog I'm heading back I'm
going to pick up Madi we're gonna go
visit Jenna I probably should shower at
some point today even with a GoPro is
water resistant up to ten feet I don't
think you guys will be joining for that
one so that's weird
these look so great bree is also coming
into town on Sunday I can't wait just be
brief
do the nails match the glasses maybe
[Music]
hi sweet pup what do you think of this
GoPro huh we're gonna strap one of these
on you how about that are you excited to
see Jenna yes you are do you like mommy
are you excited about mommy being home
wag that tail a little bit more even
though you're excited about it
[Music]
he thinks he's gonna get treat shoutout
to Sam and Jenny Starbucks you guys are
awesome
oh hi Maddie come on give me would you
here you go No let's see wait to the dog
park
[Music]
[Applause]
wow it's windy I just switched over to
the linear view so let's see what this
looks like this has been a really fun
test today okay we're gonna get the
drone out I'm gonna get a shot there's a
little swampy area there that's really
disgusting
yeah I'd like to take a peek at it I'd
like to get a nice look and see what it
see what I can see
[Music]
very successful slice I think we might
go by the beach later to check out the
sunset and hopefully get some more
really cool I don't supposed to be a go
protest blog but that in fact was not
the GoPro drone that is the Mavic drone
you guys have seen me talk about it here
we are here for the sunset in the marina
it's so beautiful
I love coming down here it's awesome I
cannot wait to fly this thing you get a
cool sunset shot
we can shiny the crowd never hesitate
let us rise to the cloud
got nothing to lose I know the time is
right
you
and I know what I know
perfect you and I and I don't know
[Music]
let us step to make night
you
night
this
[Music]
oh yeah this I wonder what's in here oh
my gosh if it's all the accessories my
heart oh no well here's the problem oh I
don't have an iPhone 7